قبل ايام من القمه العربيه المنتظره في
جده اعرب العاهل الاردني الملك عبد الله
الثاني في تصريحات لصحيفه الشرق الاوسط عن
ثقته بنجاح القمه وعبر الملك عبد الله
الثاني عن ثقته بالجهود التي يبذلها ولي
العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان التي
وفرت اعدادا جيدا يضمن نجاح القمه مشيرا
الى وجود قناعه بضروره ارساء العلاقات
العربيه العربيه على اسس صلب من التعاون
الاقتصادي وتحصينها من التباينات السياسيه
العاهل الاردني وصف النهضه الحاليه التي
تعيشها السعوديه بانها تجربه ملهمه لدول
المنطقه وان كل عربي يشعر بالفخر حيال
جهود الاصلاح والتطوير كما عبر الملك عبد
الله الثاني عن امنياته بان تكون الدول
العربيه امام فرصه جديده يمكن فيها حشد
الطاقات لفتح افاق الازدهار والاستقرار
لما فيه مصلحه الشعوب العربيه على حد قوله
[موسيقى]
انضم الينا في استديوهاتنا من الرياضه
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي والاقتصادي
حياك الله اهلا وسهلا
المتابع اليوم
لايام التي تسبق عقد قمه جده يرى ان هناك
تحضيرات مختلفه اعداد ربما لقاء التجري
قرارات ايضا سياق سياسي ربما يجعلنا نصل
الى انو او نعتقد بان هناك تغيرات في
قواعد اللعبه هي التي تقود الان الى قمه
جدا لكن السؤال ما الذي تريده السعوديه
اليوم من وراء كل هذه التحضيرات
والترتيبات التي تسبق عن عقد هذه القمه في
هذا التوقيت
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم نعتقد ان العالم
ككل والمنطقه بشكل خاص تمر بتغيرات كبيره
جدا يحتاج الان العالم العربي لقياده
لتصحيح الاوضاع وترتيب الفوضى التي كانت
موجوده في المنطقه منذ عشرين سنه منذ
الغزو الامريكي للعراق مرر العالم العربي
بعده تغيرات سواء كان على مستوى السياسي
او حتى الاقتصادي او الشعبي الثورات
العربيه الخلافات الثنائيه ما بين دول
المنطقه افرزت لنا منطقه خليني اسميها
فوضويه حان الوقت بان تستلم المملكه
العربيه السعوديه قياده بشكل مباشر وتقوده
الى الى بر الامان الان نحن في مرحله
مفصليه عالميا المنطقه بشكل خاص تحتاج الى
هذا النوع من ترتيب الاوراق وبالطبع بحكم
مكانه المملكه العربيه السعوديه وقدرتها
على القياده في هذا التوقيت تسعى لان تكون
القمه العربيه القادمه قمه فاصله وفارقه
فيفا يجب ان يتم الان العالم العربي يمر
بعده مراحل سواء كنا نتحدث ما قبل وهي
مطرح الا فاصله ما بقبل الثورات العربيه
او ما بعد الثورات العربيه
الحكومات والشعوب الامزجه الوضع الاقتصادي
ما بعد
كورونا الان العالم كله يمر متغيرات
والحلقه الاضعف ربما في هذا التوقيت هي
عندنا دول عربيه تمر في فوضى ان اكثر من
الدول العربيه تمر في فوضى عارمه اكثر لو
اخذناها اكثر من نصف الدول العربيه ايضا
تمر في ازمات اقتصاديه خانقه المزاج
العربي يجب ان يتغير يتغير الى التكامل
والتعاون وليس كمكان نتحدث سابقا عن
الوحده والعروبيه والقوميه التي كانت تقود
المنطقه بشكل عاطفي اكثر مما هو شكل منطقي
كيف تنهض المنطقه وانت لديك دوله قريبه
منك تعيش في فوضى والدوله الاخرى تعيش في
ازمه اقتصاديه والاخرى لديها مناكفت
سياسيه الان يجب ان ينتهي هذا المملكه
العربيه السعوديه تقود هذه النهضه وترى ان
الفرصه مواتيه جدا في القمه العربيه
القادمه لان تحدث تغييره بكل تاكيد النهج
السعودي الان تغير تغيرا جذريا بانه اصبحت
لا نريد الاجتماع لمجرد الاجتماع لا نريد
القمه لمجرد اخذ صورتي الكريهه الان يجب
التحرك لان يكون هناك يعني مثلا خلينا
نقول انه اهم منجز يمكن تحقق
في سياسه التصوير المشاكل الذي يتحدث عنه
الكثير من المراقبين هي مساله الاتفاق
السعودي معي بعد ذلك ما عقبه من عوده
سوريا الى جامعه الدول العربيه توجيه دعوه
ربما كذلك الى رئيس السوري لحضور هذه
القمه مرت المنطقه باجواء تشعر فيها انها
هادئه يعني لكن بعد ذلك اشتغلت في السودان
السودان ربما تعتبر حاله خاصه
تحتاج الى تفاصيل طويل ولكن الاتفاق
السعودي الايراني هذا لم ياتي من فرق
سنتين من المباحثات والمداولات وهو ليس
اتفاقا كاملا يعني حتى حتى في التصريح في
البيان الختامي هو الاتفاق على ايجاد حل
وجود ارضيه مشتركه تحديد المشاكل التعاون
في ايجاد حل هذه المشاكل وانا اعتقد ان
هذا النموذج يجب ان يطبق حتى في الدول
العربيه الاخرى هناك دول كثيره في عندها
خلافات ثنائيه ما بين هذه الدول ايضا
القناعه الكامله على يجب ان تصفر هذه
المشاكل لتجد ان لتجد الحلول لدينا الان
اكبر او اضخم مشروع تنمويه ربما في تاريخ
المنطقه رؤيه 2030 هذه الرؤيه ايضا تحتاج
الى ان تكون منطقه هادئه الامنك القومي
عمقك الاستراتيجي يبدا وليس من الدوله
المجاوره لك بل من الدوله التي تليها فما
بالك لما تكون هذه الدول لديها دين مشترك
لغه مشتركه عراق مشتركه كل عيدولوجيه
مشتركه من ذلك من المعيب ان تبقى هذه
الدول كل هذه السنوات والغريب حقيقه ان
تبقى هذه الدول كلها هذه السنوات وهي فعلا
اختلاف الان ربما الدول العربيه وجدته على
راسها المملكه العربيه السعوديه وجدت انه
الحل المشاكل العربيه يتم من خلال العرب
وليس من خلال الدول او القوى الكبرى التي
تتدخل
استطاع العرب ان يحلوا مشاكله
في جامعاتهم وفي قممهم يعني بدون مؤثرات
وبالتالي اليوم هل الوضع متغير هل يمكن
الاستفاده من الظرف لان بالفعل يدخل
الاقتصاد كقائد لقاطره عمل عربي في قمه
عربيه مختلفه في جده وين
سقف او درجه
تتوخها السعوديه وتقول بانها
القمامه التي انتجت بيانات كلام دون افعال
ركوب القطار ينطلق للتصحيح وللاصلاح يجب
على الدول الان ان تتعاون مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ركب هذا القطار نحن لا
نريد يعني القمه لن تخرج بحلول سحريه بين
يوم وليله ويكون كل شيء ورديا يعني يجب ان
يكون هناك ارضيه مشتركه اتفاق هل فعلا من
سياتي للقمه يكون يرغب فعلا بالحل ام
ستستمر المناكات وبيان ختامى لا يخرج الا
بعد شد وجذب يعني خليني اسميه
مجرد يعني ارضاء لاطراف اخرى ومجرد لكي
تخرج الصوره الجماعيه في الختام
بصوره جيده الان لم تدعو المملكه العربيه
السعوديه بهذا التوقيت الجامعه العربيه
وهذا الاهتمام الا انها تريد ان تضع حجر
الاساس نحن نريد ان اتكلم عن مملكه تريد
ان تضع حجر الاساس وتؤسس وتضع لبنه العمل
العربي المشتركي يعاد احياء بصيغه جديده
صيغه المصالح المشتركه صيغه ان النهوض يجب
ان يكون سويا الامير محمد بن سلمان قال في
عده مناسبات رؤيه 2030 هي رؤيه تكامليه
يجب ان تنهض المنطقه ككل يجب ان ننهض
جميعا حتى في مسمى لما سماها اوروبا
الجديده هذا ايضا لان هناك نظره شموليه
الان هناك قاطره تنطلق من يريد ان يكون
مرنا ويتنازل عن بعض قناعاته ويركب هذه
القاتل حياه الله اللي ما يركب هذه
القاطره الان سوف يدفع ثمنا مضاعفا لاحقا
يفوت القطار وان اراد ادراكه سوف يدفع
ثمنا مضاعفا
ليدرك هذا القطار هل هل الشعوب استوعبت هل
القيادات استوعبت هل الرغبات الان اصبحت
رغبات النهضويه اكثر ما هي واقعيه اكثر
منها شعبويه نتمنى ذلك حقيقه شكرا العبيد
الكاتب والمحنى السياسي والاقتصادي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات